In Victor's screen cast,
we also saw him navigating by landmark.
HTML5 introduced some new elements
which help us to find the semantics of
a region of the page rather than
of a single interactive element.
These are .
This represents the main
content of a page.
Typically there should
only be one main element,
since otherwise it raises the question
of which one is really the main, main.
Header, this is either a page banner
like it is here, or else a grouping
element for any introductory content
at the start of any type of section.
Footer, similarly a footer may be
either a page footer as it is here and
contain information about the page or
site.
Or maybe a footer to
a particular section of a page
with extra information
about that section.
Nav, this represents a section of a page
that links to other pages like the top
nav bar or to parts within
the page like a table of contents.
Article, this is for self-contained
sections of content like a blog entry,
news article or forum post.
A handy test for an article is
whether its content would make sense
in another context such as cross-posting
a blog post to several different blogs.
Section, this is a completely generic
section of a document or application.
Since it doesn't really give much of
a clue as to what its content might be,
we typically include
a heading inside as well.
And aside, an aside represents any
content which is tangentially related
to the content around it.
In the context of article like this
one this might be a little pull out or
sidebar.
Or in the context of a page it might
be a page sidebar containing some
extra navigation or
information about the page.
An aside will often be
rendered as a side bar.
But for example, in a responsive layout,
you might fill in a side below the main
content for small view port sizes.
There's a very good chance that your
start sheet already contains classes
like header, navigation and so on.
For example, you've got a header
a section which has a particular colour
theme and a bottom border to delineate
it from the rest of your site.
And you might want links in your
navigation section to look different
from links in the rest of the site.
Using semantic elements, provides
a more terse way to express the same
information while also potentially
providing more information for
screening ready users.
While these elements don't have any
default styling beyond just having
display block by default, you can use
your stylesheet just as you would for
a class name to select for
these elements to make them
fit your site's design.